[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes heureux de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle saison
d'auditions publiques le rendez vous du
lundi soir en direct rendez vous
politique pendant une heure à partir de
19h30 désormais sur lcp public sénat
avec le figaro premier invité marc
fesneau bonsoir vous voir le ministre
des relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne parce que demain
c'est le retour aux affaires pour vous
pour les députés en particulier qui vont
faire leur rentrée les sénateurs ce sera
un peu plus tard parce qu'il ya des
élections sénatoriales à la fin du mois
une rentrée qui sera aussi en forme de
test pour la majorité il faut bien le
dire est ce qu'elle va resté uni
jusqu'au bout et ce qu'elle sera uni
vraiment sur toutes les réformes on va
en parler tout à l'heure parce qu'il ya
de plus en plus de nuances qui s'exprime
et le modem n'est pas le dernier à
exprimer ses nuances quand il le faut le
modem qui renforce ses positions
d'ailleurs à l'assemblée nationale
françois bayrou il revenu dans les
cercles du pouvoir vous êtes un proche
et certainement pas pour jouer des
observateurs mais ça on attend d'y
revenir
une première question vous avez votre
téléphone portable avec vous oui il
n'est pas la 5g encore n'ont pas encore
et 5 g c'est pour bientôt mais ça fait
débat
la 5g vous avez vu qu'il ya des élus de
gauche des mers europe ecologie les
verts qui ont lancé un appel pour
demander de reporter d'un an
l'appel d'offres pour la 5 j'ai le temps
de voir quelles pourraient être les
risques pour la santé et l'environnement
le gouvernement n'est pas prêt à
reporter sa d'un an pourquoi il ya si
urgence que ça mais parce que c'est une
technologie qui progresse très
rapidement
nous ne sommes pas sur une île déserte
au milieu du monde sans que d'autres
pays n'avance sur ces questions-là
singes et c'est valable dans les états
unis c'est valable évidemment en chine
c'est valable dans tous les pays
européens
alors ce n'est pas non plus un dogme
disant que c'est forcément une avancée
formidable mais manifestement il ya un
certain nombre d' usage qui pourront
être démultipliée par la 5g j'entends
parfois les uns des inquiétudes qui peut
y avoir mais on a eu des tas
d'inquiétude écueils des révolutions
technologiques et la 5g et une
révolution technologique est toujours
des craintes qui se manifeste et la
crainte de la chine aussi parce que
c'est elle qui menez il ya deux types de
crainte de deux des craintes de nature
qui porte sur la science elle-même
je trouve que de plus en plus on
s'appuie pas assez sur la science est ce
que dit la science est parfois sur un
postulat idéologique je peux respecter
mais enfin ce n'est pas la science
postulat idéologique et puis de des
craintes et ça il appartient
au gouvernement français aux autorités
françaises aussi aux autorités
européennes de faire en sorte que dans
ce contexte de déploiement de la 5g nous
gardions aussi notre part d'indépendance
et d'autonomie reconnaît la souveraineté
dessous mais reconnaissons que les
gaffes en lega femmes comme on dit c'est
souveraineté nous a largement échappé ce
qu'il faut passer ce qu'il ne faut pas
c'est qu'il faut que ça s'accentue en
attend je le dis d'autant plus
permettez-moi de le dire pour ceux qui
ne regardent nous écoute on parle
beaucoup de 5 g il ya beaucoup de
territoires aussi qu'ils attendent déjà
la 3g ou la 4g qui savent eux les zones
blanches vous êtes un élu rural hors
d'un côté il y en a qui auront la 5g les
autres qui seront en zone blanche les
électeurs et c'est ce qu'on est en train
de faire sur la fibre au fond on est en
train de rattraper le retard immense qui
avait en termes de déploiement de la
fibre et qui permet y compris dans un
territoire comme le mien je j'étais
maire d'une commune de 700 habitants
d'avoir de la fibre maison par
habitation par habitant mais vous ne
craignez pas une france à deux vitesses
celle de la cendre et 16 autres volonté
c'est que le sottoli l'aimé mais c'est
l'objectif d'une gouvernance qu'il faut
éviter c'est que le saut technologique
produise de nouveau une distorsion donc
en clair les opérateurs ont néocons
évident ce qui s'est passé sur la 3g et
la 4g qui a fait qu'au fond les gens que
ça veut dire quoi concrètement comment
les opérateurs vont devoir prendre des
engagements est évidemment dans le
partenariat qui doit sonner dans l'appel
d'offres qui doit semer il ya des
engagements qui doivent être tenus par
les opérateurs comme on est en train
d'essayer enfin de les faire tenir leurs
engagements sur la 3 et la 4 g ce sera
lié à la 5g
mais pour les territoires ruraux la 5g
c'est un outil formidable par exemple en
termes de télémédecine donc on peut pas
non plus privé des territoires qui sont
les plus éloignés des pôles urbains de
ce que peuvent elles en tête mais ce que
j'ai entendu ce soir de votre part sait
qu'il devra y avoir des engagements des
opérateurs pour aussi cibler les zones
blanches il ya des charges de la 5g on
peut pas l'objectif n'est pas de creuser
le fossé
l'objectif c'est que tout le monde
puisse donc ça fera partie des ouvriers
des charmants ça fait partie du crédit
ça voilà pour la cinquième et la
préoccupation numéro un des français en
ce moment c'est le coronavirus de
nouvelles mesures de restriction ont été
décidés à bordeaux et à marseille là
dans l'après midi c'est par cela que
nous commençons avec thème traduite
public sénat et jean boucher de lcp qui
nous qui sont sur ce plat toi on pense à
marc fesneau effectivement un de
nouvelles restrictions en gironde dans
les bouches du rhône
est ce que c'est ce qui attend
finalement les 42 départements classés
rouge qui ont été annoncées à la fin de
la semaine dernière pas forcément vous
avez vu la logique qui a été présenté
par le premier ministre que ce soit une
bonne logique était d'abord une logique
de responsabilisation collective nous a
parfois reproché d'être trop descendants
et au fond de dire que chaque territoire
et chacun d'entre nous dans ces actes et
dans ses gestes quotidiens il porte une
part de responsabilité au sens noble
du terme pas pour vilipender qui que ce
soit mais je pense que c'est un élément
important et 2 l'idée c'est qu'à des cas
développer aussi le prémunit c'est la
volonté que nous avons que territoire
par territoire on regarde en fonction de
l' évolution épidémique mais il ya
quarante-deux départements ils sont là
dans la rue avec la même couleur la
couleur c'est la dynamique épidémique
mais vous voyez bien que les zones de
tension en hospitalisation sont pas de
même nature son nom tel ou tel
territoire et donc c'est dans ce
cadre-là croquant qu'il faut regarder
les choses quand vous êtes dans un
territoire peu denses évidemment la
circulation du virus quand bien même
elle est active épouse moins de
contraintes que quand vous entendez un
territoire très dense où le fait qu'on
soit les proches les uns des autres
favorisent la propagation du virus et
donc vous devez prendre des mesures plus
à marseille qu'ailleurs
voilà c'est aussi simple que ça mais moi
je voulais saluer le travail qui a été
fait par les préfets avec les
collectivités territoriales
vous avez cité le cas de la gironde qui
ont essayé de faire un travail
approfondi précis j'écoutais hier renaud
muselier la région de la région paca qui
saluait plutôt le travail madame
rebeyrol aouchiche qu'on l'a fait à
marseille qui salue le travail de
coopération territoriale pour regarder
au mieux ou plutôt que ça marcherait
avec le maire écologiste de bordeaux ont
pas perdre espoir ya le préfet des
bouches du rhône qui annonce le port du
masque obligatoire dans 27 communes
or on voit qu'aujourd'hui même le masque
obligatoire a été retoqué à strasbourg
il ya eu des recours qui ont été
déposées pour paris pour nice pour lyon
alors est-ce finalement est ce que ça
peut faire jurisprudence et battre en
brèche un peu la stratégie du
gouvernement qui est d'imposer le masque
ce casque avait dit tribunal
administratif à strasbourg c'était que
compte tenu de ce qui était l'état de
diffusion du virus
et compte tenu de ce qu'était la
typologie strasbourg y avait peut-être
pas besoin d'avoir une mesure de nature
générale les décisions qui sont prises
sont marseille sont là dans
l'agglomération dans les rues urbaine de
marseille bien que là on a une
continuité urbaine et par ailleurs fois
des foyers épidémiques qui sont très
violents il sent que ça justifie d'une
mesure qui soit une mesure de nature
générale après ceux qui veulent aller au
tribunal administratif le fond on est
dans un état de droit se justifie bah on
n'est pas dans la situation de marseille
en termes de foyers épidémiques
justement non mais on peut aussi prendre
des mesures de précaution préalable pour
éviter de se retrouver dans des
situations parce que dans le cas de
marseille ou dans le cas de bordeaux
revient qu on a des situations qui sont
déjà des situations de tension
épidémique et donc il faut une section
arrivé trop tard ces décisions n'ont
elles sont pas arrivés trop tard mais
on voit bien sur cette question de la
crise épidémique du coc vie depuis le
mois de janvier depuis le mois de
février on voit bien que c'est très
difficile pour les citoyens pour les
autorités publiques c'est pas valable
qu'en france de prendre des décisions
dans que le risque n'apparaît pas c'est
difficile de dire le risque arrive sans
être dans une situation de stress
vis-à-vis des citoyens
on essaie d'ajuster le dispositif et je
crois qu'il faut mieux et on le font
mieux que les territoires vous avez
féliciter tout à l'heure les préfets qui
prennent des décisions au niveau du
territoire et les collectivités logist
mais il ya aussi et bien je pense que
les préfets ces élus qui demandent eux
un cadre national qui vous accusent de
vous défausser sur les territoires ce
qui va pas falloir quand même un cadre
avec une unité nationale il faudrait
qu'on ait un discours pour ceux qui ont
ce discours là un discours homogène ce
sont parfois les mêmes qui dit cela et
qui au mois de janvier février mars nous
disait il faut nous laisser faire dans
les territoires c'est les mêmes qui
disent il faut faire de la
différenciation territoriale qu' on
puisse discuter avec madame le maire de
marseille
les autorités sanitaires le préfet pour
regarder en fonction des événements
qu'il y à des manifestations qui sont
organisées de la situation de tel ou tel
quartier les mesures qui affaire où elle
mauvais mais voilà on avait brossé avec
un essai de la ferc amant un cas précis
c'est quand même vraiment compliqué par
exemple le cas des écoles n'a beaucoup
de personnes qui estiment que c'est le
grand flou des endroits où lorsqu'il ya
un enfant qui tombe malade et bien on
ferme la classe voire l'école d'autres
endroits aussi tout à fait possible est
ce qu'il faudrait pas là encore une
véritable galère orientations qui ont
été donnés nucléaire national après il
ya d une autonomie quand même des chefs
d'établissement et des directeurs
d'établissements qui ne savent pas quoi
faire qui sont parfois démunis on va
mais essayons de regarder les cas qui
peuvent poser problème n'en faisons pas
ce que j'ai horreur qu'on fasse je sais
pas dit que c'est ce que vous faisiez
vous mais des généralités
c'est toujours la même chose les grosses
responsabilités pour les directeurs
d'école on a nommé jeu chacun porte sa
part de responsables mais le directeur
des nouvelles je ne dis pas que il faut
leur faire porter toute la charge de la
responsabilité mais le directeur d'école
moi je suis dans un dans un village où
l'école et les classes on continue les
unes des autres à la cantine c'est
continuer les uns des autres c'est pas
pareil que quand vous avez un grand
réfectoire vous êtes capable de faire
deux services le directeur d'école il
peut donner une orientation sans qu'on
lui fasse porter la charge d'une
responsabilités trop lourdes mais c'est
quand même pas idiot
se disent dans telle école ça fonctionne
comme ça et donc là il faut peut-être
prendre telle mesure et dans telle autre
ça fonctionne comme ça on peut peut-être
ajusté comme ça les muses nymphes et ne
reste qu'un reconstruisez moi c'est une
chance
est ce qu un recond finement nationale
et totalement écarté aujourd'hui c'est
pas la volonté du gouvernement le
premier cela réitéré ces écarts étaient
ou pas mais le premier ministre a
manifesté la volonté qu'on avait de ne
pas procéder à un recompte finaliser un
accord l'économie prime aujourd'hui sur
le sanitaire ce qui n'a pas été le cas
ce n'est pas que la question l'économie
prime sur le sanitaire et vous a pas
échappé que la crise du cours d'un virus
a émergé très violemment pas que chez
nous au mois de janvier février que nous
avions un sujet qui n'était qui était à
la fois la contamination mais surtout
l'engorgement des urgences
nous sommes avec six mois de délai donc
un certain nombre de choses qui sont
mieux prises en charge
on voit mieux qu'on peut mieux anticiper
comme dans la plupart des pays européens
les situations et donc l'idée de re
confiné brutalement ce qu'on l'a fait
dans quasiment tous les pays du monde à
l'exception de quelques et originaux
dans la démarche si je peux dire non je
pense pas je pensais pas là ce fait que
la suède était stratégie assumée je
pense aux états unis par fermer aux
parieurs où on a assumé l'idée qu après
tout c'était pas grave et que le
coronavirus n'était pas grave la suède
en plei nos stratégies l'accord ceci dit
quand on regarde le ratio de
contamination et de mort par habitant
c'est pas forcément non plus n'ont verra
un bon processus moi je pense qu'il faut
être modeste les uns et les autres
fameux pas juger les uns les autres et
donc là est la volonté qu'on a cédé
vitter au conflit en général c'est pas
que l'économie prime parce que tout ça
est lié sait que ce n'est pas seulement
une question d'économie voyez bien
coller ce qu'on a pu parfois dénoncé à
mon avis peut-être pour certains trop
trop fort quand vous êtes jeune vous
avez 20 ans et que vous avez envie de
vous réunir vous n'allez pas confiné un
pays pendant six mois huit mois dix mois
12 mois c'est impossible socialement
abdallah économique c'est une question
sociale mais on a une responsabilité
sanitaire en première étape hier le
confinement aujourd'hui on passe à la
généralisation des tests
d'ailleurs une phase que certains
scientifiques a notamment devant la
commission d'enquêté du sénat la semaine
dernière qualifie de fiasco alors
aujourd'hui quelle est votre stratégie
c'est une stratégie europe là aussi
janvier février mars on était moins nous
disait on teste pas assez désormais qu
est ce qu on nous dit vous testez trop
enfin c'est les mêmes qui se rompent
leurs priorités à la tête alors on ne
puisse pas suffi deuxième élément le
premier ministre compte tenu de ceux de
cet afflux effectivement qui a eu deux
temps
certain nombre de départements décrivant
la réalité telle qu'elle est pas la
peine de se cacher a décidé qu'il y
aurait des créneaux horaires et des
priorisations qui serait fait pour que
ceux qui l'ont été qu'à contacter ce qui
manifestement des symptômes soient
prioritaires sur
qui par précaution ont décidé qu'ils
risquent d'attendre quand même pendant
dix jours les réseaux non l'idée c'est
que ceux qui sont manifestement les plus
en danger des porteurs du virus ou pour
des proches puissent attester plus
rapide
mais à voir le pétrole
alors
voir le résultat le plus vite
et bien que ça peut être une difficulté
c'est que vous soyez tester rapidement
et encore mieux
sur les élections départementales et
régionales doivent se tenir en mars
prochain
est-ce qu'il faut envisager un report
est ce qu'il faut éventuellement
discuter avec les partis on se souvient
que ça avait pu créer des problèmes au
moment des municipales
je n'entends personne à ce stade d'en
parler mais la question vous levez le
bonne question qui est complètement
comment dirais-je saugrenue saugrenue je
me souviens très bien de l'épisode des
municipales et des procès qui ont été
faits de part et d'autre soit parce que
nous voulions éludé le débat municipal
soit parce que nous avions à toute force
décidé de tenir ce premier tour nous
n'en sommes pas là nous sommes au mois
de septembre mais en tout cas que vous
exprimer
comment est ce que vous vous y préparer
non non pas dans les annales on est jeté
ce que je voulais vous dire on est en
septembre
on est déjà dans une phase de rebond
épidémique certains parlent de deuxième
vague peu importe la terminologie qu'on
emploie nous sommes en septembre et on
verra au fur et à mesure mais ça peut
être comme tout sur tous les sujets de
la vie sociale ça peut être un point de
vigilance mais cela comme un autre ce
sera en discussion un autre ce serait en
discussion avec tous les partis
politiques vous éviterez le procès qu'on
vous a pris il ya quelques mois j'ai
assisté aux discussions j'avais le
sentiment que tout était alors faudra
changer quelque chose pour toi plus il
est en tout cas s'il ce débat devait
avoir lieu c'est pas le sujet du jour
rendons le plus explicite pour que tout
le monde se sente à l'aise alors vous
êtes mise des relations avec le
parlement les députés font leur rentrée
demain et ben comment ça va se passer
les mois et les semaines qui viennent
voilà on aimerait bien savoir quels sont
les textes prioritaires pour cette année
parlementaire
tout simplement
une proposition de loi
sur l'est
projet une expérimentation
qui a plutôt bien marché pour essayer de
faire en sorte que les gens qui sont
depuis longtemps éloignées de l'emploi
puceau
terme puissant nous avons un projet de
loi sur la réforme du cee qui vise à en
modifier économique conseil
environnemental
vous avez raison que j'essaie d'éviter
des agronomes dit comme ça là j'ai fait
défaut c'était une réforme qui était
voulu par le président de la république
ça faisait partie du paquet
institutionnel est bon ça c'est acquis
et donc s'il ya des choses en suisse et
je ne sais pas qui sous la réserve du
vote des parlementaires
c'est dans le gîte c'est dans le
développement et troisième sujet
important c'est le projet de la
programmation de la recherche qui est
dans les moments qu'on vit on voit bien
comme nous on aura des besoins de
recherche et après on va avoir une
grande séquencée il sera la séquence
essentiel du budget projet de loi de
finances projet loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale dans lequel nous aurons
évidemment le volet plan de relance le
séparatisme par exemple cette loi sur le
séparatisme est ce qu'elle aura lieu en
2021 donc après l'autre
pau trets est prévu aussi à l'agenda
2020 thérèse que ça rende dans le
calendrier parlementaire tout comme le
les textes qui doivent mener au
référendum pour pour le climat alors
plusieurs sujets sur la loi sur le
séparatisme marlène schiappa gérald
darmanin déjà parlé du décès de d'avoir
de lancer un certain nombre de débats et
de dialogue avec les associations afin
qu'un certain nombre d'acteurs de ce
sujet de ce sujet là l'objectif étant
que la fin de l'automne début d'hiver on
est un texte soit présenté en conseil
des ministres sa veut dire que le débat
parlementaire peut se dérouler au
premier semestre 2021 sans que je puisse
vous donner à ce stade une date plus de
100 ans en 2021 l'objectif c'est de 1021
deuxième sujet vous avez évoqué la loi
sur les retraites où l'éventuel projet
de loi sur les retraites le premier nist
a été assez clair il a dit il faut
regarder
est ce qu'on a besoin de reposer la
question est ce que la question de la
réforme des retraites reste pendante la
réponse est oui
question de son financement aussi
l'atelier va dès le premier ministre a
dit il faut regarder les conditions qui
permettront d'avoir un débat qui
permette d'avancer sur ce sujet sans se
retrouver dans une compliqué 2020 heures
il sera 2021
ça dépendra de la temporalité des
conditions ce n'est pas acquis roues le
sujet existe ne mettons pas soult avait
déjà acquis pour 2022 mais on verra les
conditions dans lesquelles peuvent se
dérouler dès les premières minutes il du
quinquennat dans ce si vous le faites
pas nous avoir fait la hausse il
reproche que je veux bien tout en temps
de peut-être parfois avoir été trop
audacieux sur cette réforme des
retraites et quand le premier ministre
dit il faut comprendre north débattent
avec les partenaires sociaux escape un
chemin trouvé entre nous sur le
financement sur l' équilibre sur les
grands attendue du système et sur une
meilleure justice du système de retraite
donc attendons cela et après nous
verrons si elle a posté les texans le
référendum juste climat dont le
président la république a été assez
clair il a dit ian convention citoyenne
peut être qu'on en reparlera tout à
l'heure elle va là elle a produit un
certain nombre de propositions qui sont
assez remarquables d'ailleurs je le dis
au passage désormais c'est dans le débat
parlementaire il ya un travail qui est
fait avec le gouvernement avec les
citoyens et ensuite avec les
parlementaires qui permettra d'avoir un
projet de loi le président de la
république ayant dit si nous allions à
l'échec sur un projet de loi y avait
trop de conflits qualité giraud
référendum c'est dans ces conditions là
qu'il avait alors le gros morceau de
l'automne vous l'avez disent les textes
budgétaires a notamment le budget 2021
qui va porter le plan de relance alors
selon le pré
dans de la commission des finances à
l'assemblée eric woerth
les délais d'examen sont trop courts en
fait il ya deux ans les députés avaient
eu onze jours entre moment il avait
connu le texte et le moment ils
pouvaient déposer les amendements
l'année dernière c'était une semaine et
cette année c'est seulement deux jours
est-ce que c'est trop court
et est ce que vous allez faire quelque
chose pour leur accorder plus de temps
la réponse est oui et la réponse est oui
d'accord qu'elle fasse ce que j'entends
complètement ce que dit le président
woerth est ce que dit le rapporteur
général laurent saint martin je
comprends tout à fait parce que je
n'oublie pas que j'ai été parlementaire
et par ailleurs je suis mise des
relations avec le parlement et donc il
faut qu'on essaie d examiner les textes
en dit long contrat idéal est deux
secondes
donc on va regarder jouer on verra
demain à la conférence des présidents
j'en parlerai vous permettrai de le dire
la conférence des présidents on va
regarder comment on peut faire en sorte
qu'ils aient plus de délai reconnaissons
aussi avant la présentation
oui oui oui la présentation d'une perche
et ministre et de présentation du budget
reconnaissons aussi que pour le
ministère de l'économie des finances du
ministère des comptes publics budget
classique + plan de relance d'une charge
de travail qui était très d'autres mais
j'entends aussi ce que disent les
parlementaires c'est que ils veulent des
comptes ce 50 ce sera quoi il ya une
semaine ça peut ressembler à quelque
chose de cet ordre l'antenne ce que veut
donner plus de temps parlementaire
conséquence elle a vu que j'ai encore du
budget de la rue jour de 3 $ ça peut
ressembler à ça de 27,27 dialogue demain
en conférence des présidents en tout cas
je ne suis pas sourd à cette demande que
je trouve légitime il y passe ou la
conférence des présidents et la majorité
parlementaire qui se remet en ordre de
marche pour cette rentrée notamment
autour du modem de givet le groupe modem
qui va annoncer l'arrivée d'une bonne
partie de nouveaux députés issus avant
tout quand même de la république en
marche
finalement à quoi ça sert vous vous
cherchez à faire quoi avec ces
ralliements de la république en marche
moi je ne cherche rien je vais vous dire
la philosophie qui l'amène sur ces
affaires là il ya un certain nombre de
groupes dans lesquels qui ne sont pas ni
la république en marche ni le modem ni
agir d'ailleurs qu'ils sont pliés dans
l'est qui compte au sein de leurs moins
de leur groupe
des membres qui manifestement plutôt ont
plutôt à défaut de bienveillance en tout
cas une attention particulière avec la
politique que nous menons
on voit bien que dans les votes qui
s'éclate les un vote contre la confiance
les autres s'abstiennent les troisièmes
vote pour
je pense que la première oeuvre dans une
assemblée c'est qu'on est un peu de
clarté en un groupe il est dans la
majorité où il est dans l'opposition
alors après peut-être constructive ou
pas du tout constructive
chacun est juge de la façon dont on gère
l'opposition mais il me semble qu'ils
avaient besoin de clarté
c'est ce qui s'est passé par exemple
avec le groupe libertaire territoire
c'est ce qui se passe aussi pour un
membre du groupe
eds qui avait il ne se retrouvait pas
dans l'idée d'un groupe qui soit dans
l'opposition frontale avec le
gouvernement
quant aux affaires de groupe entre m et
la réplique en marche
je les dis d'ailleurs à patrick mignola
je les dis à christophe castaner que
j'ai vu tout à l'heure moi je pense
qu'il faut éviter ce genre de mouvements
là il ya des individualités dont on sait
depuis longtemps qu'elle pouvait être
mal à l'aise dans tel ou tel groupe
qu'il puisse y avoir des mouvements
marginaux
certes mais ça ne peut pas être au
moment où on essaie de construire une
maison commune de construire une
relation d'interbrew à des débauchages
de la part d un strict minium ya un
certain nombre de jeux je ne crois pas
que c'était des débauchages bien certain
nombre de gens qui depuis des mois
certains étaient groupés rmi sont
devenus apparentés parfois pour des
affaires de mu nicipal parfois pour des
affaires plus personnelles
peu importe je pense qu'il faut pas
procéder donc doc en clair vous siffler
la fin de la récréation je pense que ça
ne peut être la voie d'un dialogue entre
deux groupes ou 3 de la majorité ont
qu'une dizaine ça suffira on n'en parle
plus après c'est ça je parle
vous m'avez interrogé sur un sujet vous
me parliez je vois bien qu'il était
l'objet de votre question des députés de
la république en main moi je pense que
si on veut nouer un dialogue
on peut se parler entre grandes filles
et grand garçon de difficultés qu'il
peut y avoir de telles ou telles
individualités mais ça peut pas être une
stratégie générale et ça c'est un
message via des vidéos l'artiste cours
là aussi un message à patrick mignola
mais jusque jeudi la juge qui va
chercher mais patrick connaît très bien
ma position
il a entendu votre message et je crois
qu'il a entendu mon message et je crois
qu'il n'a pas autre chose en tête
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui s'en
est encore elle d'ailleurs très profonde
avec la république en marche pour
certains d'entre eux qui n'ont pas de
difficulté particulière mais qui avait
une forme d' envie d'aller dans un autre
groupe où il doit se limiter ça doit
être fait dans la clarté et sans
préciser pour sentiment contre les six
heymans et concordia légers entre vous
le dites fragiles en relations première
réunion entre 12h06 au parlement pour
ces viols il ya une première réunion
commune demain du groupe
la république en marche des députés du
modem et des députés agir va y avoir
quatorze ministres
à quoi ça sert cette réunion
d'intergroupe à ce que c'est une
opération de com
j'ai pas du tout
horatio de communication vous ne vous
aura pas échappé vous l'avez dit
vous-même que c'est la rentrée
parlementaire que la rentrée
parlementaire on sait les deux sujets
dont on a parlé elle est ponctuée par la
situation sanitaire et deux par le plan
de relance par la volonté de au delà du
budget même si dans les éléments
budgétaires il ya déjà des choses par le
plan de relance de 100 milliards d'euros
comme on essaie de relancer l'économie
et que nous poussions avec les 12 et 14
ministres avec les quatorze ministres
porter un certain nombre de de débat
portait un certain nombre de
questionnements corps et le groupe de la
majorité c'est pas une question du tout
rien pardon
rien de plus normal et légitime que les
groupes de la majorité voit les
ministres pour parler du plan de relance
au fond rien de très original pouvoir
que nourrit aussi un peu les rangs non
c'est pas une question de resserrer les
rangs c'était une question de débat ne
cherchez pas des dédits ya suffisamment
difficulté par ailleurs pour ne pas
chercher des difficultés là il y en a
pas c'est pas une clarté dans les rangs
la majorité sur le plan de relance je
peux vous le dire elle est tout à fait
corps blanc est tout à fait homogène ça
n'empêche pas qu'il puisse y avoir on a
parlé des députés mais il ya des
élections sénatoriales de quelque chose
c'est la dernière qui est ce mot sur le
sénat les élections sénatoriales
effectivement dans deux semaines le
groupe e la république en marche presque
de sortir de là affaiblie alors comment
élargir un groupe justement est ce que
pour vous il faut plutôt un intergroupe
faire en sorte que tout le monde se
parle il reste dans le même groupe ou
plutôt un groupe élargi
un seul une moi je n'ai pas à me mêler
des organisations des groupes pardon de
vous le dire
alors qu'est-ce qui est le plus petit
recul à vous deux vous préjuger du
résultat électoral moi juge par nature
par construction et par expérience je
sais de ne pas préjuger de ce qui se
passera le 27 septembre à laisser faire
les dents et lecteurs qui détermineront
les équilibres cas au sénat après les
élections municipales un certain abandon
après cautionary refusé de répondre à
votre question ou puisse essayer
d'identifier ceux qui qu'ils soient de
la république en marche qu'ils soient
dans groupe uc qui soit dans le groupe
liberté et territoires même parfois en
groupe r d se ont plutôt envie sans être
complètement en ligne avec la position
gouvernementale de manifester leur
soutien sur tel ou tel texte
ça c'est un travail à faire le format
dans lequel il faut faire il était
déterminé à partir il n'y a pas d'option
partenariat de votre site et ça
tranquillement
merci tam merci brigitte légaliser ou
pâle que le cannabis la question est
relancé depuis la mise en place d'une
amende qui vise les fumeurs vous savez
c'est gérald darmanin qui a lancé ça
parce qu'il estime que c'est comme ça
qu'on peut assécher les réseaux de
trafiquants le miz de l'intérieur est
revenu sur la question ce matin sur lci
il était plutôt cash
la drogue c'est la merde quand j'étais
gamin à la télévision dans les années 80
il y avait un spot jeu pas si vous vous
rappelez la drogue c'est de la main
mais ils luttent contre cette merde on
va pas légaliser cette merde voilà en
tout cas moi je le dis avec témoin je
crois de tous les parents que j'ai déjà
reçu dans ma permanence d'élu accusé
monsieur le maire aidé nous voilà donc
ma façon de les aider c'est lutter
contre les trafics lutter contre les
délais consommation mais aussi il faut
bien le dire passer un message je crois
de fermeté la drogue
effectivement c'est de la merde marc
fesneau c'est de la merde de cannabis
chaque emploi les motifs de moi je vais
sur le fond est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui est nocif et toxique oui donc
pas d'égalisation à votre sens que par
ailleurs il faut pas envoyer des
messages contradictoires on peut pas à
la fois dire on procède par amendes ont
essayé de lutter contre le trafic et
dans le même temps dire on pourrait
ouvrir la voie à la légalisation du
cannabis et une politique où c'est une
autre fait vous je finis il me semble
qu'il faut quand même exploré la voie
parce qu'on voit bien que puissamment
dans un certain nombre de quartiers
c'est ce qui nourrit le trafic et il n'a
pas toujours été démontré que la
légalisation est complètement mis à bas
la question des trafics
ceci dit on est on est un pays il faut
aussi se poser la question dans lequel
la diction en particulier le cannabis
est un des plus fort le plus fortement
répandue au monde dont il ya une
question de
est-ce que c'est l'interdiction qu'il
produit pas serré mais j'ai envie d'être
des voix votre avis moi je suis pas en
première intuition pour la légalisation
du cannabis je suis pas obtus fermé à la
partition que george a commenté hier
pardon oui
j'entendais hier ce que disait renaud
muselier je partage assez son avis et on
a une politique depuis des années qui
est une politique d c'est lutter contre
les trafics éthique une politique qui
est dans le cadre d'une non légalisation
du cannabis
essayons cette politique essayant de
l'approfondir oui mais quelque chose
d'intéressant on pouvait mener des
expériences remercie le maire les
républicains de reims arnaud robinet
douche vous ils voudraient tester la
dépénalisation dans sa ville est-ce
qu'il faut lui accorder ce droit à
l'expérimentation
ah ça fait partie des droits à
l'expérimentation peuvent réclamer des
mers faut écouter ce que disent les
maires peut-être qu'il faut regarder ça
mais moi je ne les mesures de
généralisation la sepa généralisation
l'expérimentation elle a pour but pas
d'expérimenter seulement à reims elle a
pour but de montrer que ces droits
cassou pas comme ça oui de voir après
faire une expérimentation
personnellement c'est un avis tout à
fait personnel mais je trouve qu'on peut
pas changer de cap et changer de
politique en permanence qu'il faut
conduite puissamment contre les trafics
de drogue et il faut quand même tourné
un discours
pour dire que au fond le cannabis n'est
pas quelque chose d'anodin c'est pas
quelque chose on voit bien le germain
pas tous ne généralisons pas on voit
bien le chemin que prennent un certain
nombre de gens commençant par le
caennais bibeau parfois d'autres ils
voient bien même quand on est que
consommateur de cannabis les effets que
ça peut produire ce n'est pas une
affaire neutre donc c'est pas illégitime
que nous soyons sur une mesure
d'interdiction par craignait que des
merveilles expérimentés pourquoi pas
regarder pourquoi pas et il ya aussi des
expérimentations qui ont lieu à paris
sur des salles de shoot autant le soudan
autre chose oui mais je veux dire on est
déjà sur un dos tres bien plus élevé est
bien plus heureux et met d'accord mais
c'est beaucoup plus dur à autre chose
donc mais je veux dire il ya déjà eu des
expérimentations ça serait pas une
révolution industrielle si je peux dire
bien et bien cette saison on retrouve
yves thréard du figaro qui est avec nous
[Musique]
bonsoir yves éditorialistes et directeur
adjoint du figaro jeudi tout oui bonsoir
marc fesneau
bonsoir les élections municipales ont
été catastrophiques pour la majorité
présidentielle
comment vous envisagez ces élections
régionales et départementales qui se
profile au mois de mars prochain
si elles ont lieu elles auront lieu
c'est pas la question comment vous allez
faire pour éviter la catastrophe
c'est moi je vois sur les élections qui
viennent de vendre alors parce que ce
qui nous attend on est bien d'accord
quand vous avez commencé par le passé
elles ont été difficiles il ya eu des
tas de déceptions il ya aussi un certain
nombre de gens qui sont rentrés dans les
équipes municipales
j'ai adhéré au modem dans la suite de
l'udf en 2007 2008 elle n'avait pas été
bonne non plus pourquoi parce que quand
vous êtes un parti émergents sur la
place publique et que vous n'avez pas
encore l'ancrage il faut du temps et la
république en marche a procédé à une
première commande et rennes oeuvre
d'ancrage territorial et reparlons-en
d'ancizan et on verra que l'ancrage à
porter ses fruits il faut un peu se met
à dire qu'en six ans vous serez encore
et toujours avoir espoir d'être là dans
six ans on se souhaite plutôt bonne
santé après politiquement verra après
pour les aidants cet élément de
difficultés que nous avons eues
municipal nous avons
même en difficulté sur un certain nombre
de divisions l'avenir maintenant et donc
ça nécessite pour les élections qui
viennent devant nous d'essayer de les
regarder dans un esprit c'est la volonté
aussi qui est porté par les responsables
de la majorité au travers de ce qu'on
appelle la maison commune de faire
ensemble de nous alignons nos stratégies
région par région en particulier parce
que c'est là que c'est le plus prégnant
pour faire en sorte
comment dirais-je d'affronter cet
épisode électoral avec avec une forme de
cohérence collective et c'est savoir la
base des choses il alors si on regarde
un petit peu le passé si on regarde des
élections régionales précédentes on
s'aperçoit que le modem était avec qui
il était avec les républicains et donc
est ce que la hausse et élections
régionales vous allez faire cause
commune avec les républicains si on
pouvait un peu distingué les situations
si vous me permettez de le direction
n'est pas de fer avec les républicains
ou de fer avec les socialistes
qu'est ce que je vois le party les
républicains et le parti socialiste sont
dans une confrontation que je considère
malheureusement un peu comme stériles au
gouvernement et une confrontation
mécanique pavlovienne y compris parfois
dans un certain nombre de régions il ya
un certain nombre de régions qui porte
en lan en leur sein des risques de
bascule au front national donc le regard
n'est pas portée de la même façon et
qu'elle en paca par exemple hors de
france
et là vous pourriez faire cause commune
lalaurie sais plus mais on a su que j en
connais mais je pense qu'il ya quand
même des exigences de degré supérieur
mais il faut regarder et il faut t'il
encore à voir avec nous ou à côté de
nous ceux qui participent de l'idée
qu'un moment l'essentiel est en jeu et
qu'on ne peut pas sur des sujets comme
cela jouer aux équilibres salengro
république et un an que je n'aime pas le
terme de front républicain parce que je
pense que c'est une espèce d'abord je
suis pas sûre de son efficacité
désormais mais l'idée de dire que on
porte sur la région quand même plus de
choses qu'on partage même si on a des
différences que on partage avec le
rassemblement national ça me paraît bon
sens je l'entendais parler de renaud
muselier à propos de la drogue tout à
l'heure vous pourriez très bien faire
cause commune avec lui dans région
provence alpes côte d'azur la question
le
je pose les termes du débat dans ces
régions là n'est pas posée que vos
responsables de la majorité elle et pour
elle est posée aux questions aux
responsables de leurs et de l'arrêt des
républicains pardon c'est aussi qu'ils
devront s'interroger mais je pense qu'il
faut le faire dans le dialogue et dans
la responsable il faut préval un esprit
de responsabilité par ailleurs ce que je
constate c'est que les uns veulent faire
delà des régionales
un premier round et c'est pour la
primaire à droite les autres valent en
faire un test d'opposition ou pas au
gouvernement
moi je voudrais qu'on soit sur le sujet
le sujet c'est les régionales le sujet
c'est de mettre en place des exécutifs
non pas qu'il soit totalement alignée
avec le gouvernement mais qui ne soit
pas en permanence dans une logique
d'affrontement
et alors qu'on a une crise sanitaire on
a une crise et collectionneuse qui joue
à la proportionnelle attendez que les
régions sont des outils puissants de la
relance économique et qu'on a besoin
d'elle
d'accord vraiment besoin d'elle une
situation je trouve qu'il a une voix
elle était partiellement il ya une
situation assez particulière parce qu'il
ya plusieurs présidents de conseils
régionaux en france qui ont quand même
quelques petites ambitions
présidentielles qui sont précisément
plutôt à droite
est-ce que avant une élection
présidentielle qui est celle de 2022
vous pourriez vous alliez avec madame
pécresse à paris avec monsieur vous qui
est auvergne avec monsieur bertrand dans
l'hérault de france paris la question
elle est valable pour tout champ
politique c est ce qu on partage un
socle et de valeurs est programmatique
2 est ce qu'on parle de l'enjeu régional
où on parle d'autre chose
moi j'entends certains qui disent c'est
je veux être celui qui sera le mieux élu
ou celui qui montrera que dans une
primaire par exemple à droite au fond
sur le champ gauche et pas et puisque
c'est une bataille entre les juristes
est le parti socialiste je pense que ça
n'est pas le sujet reste xavier engrand
sakidi l'éloigneront nous de la volonté
de faire de cette élection une élection
qui soit un premier round pour 2022
chanteuse lhasa historiquement j'en
conclus que votre adversaire principal
c'est évidemment le rassemblement
national et madame le pen bas une seule
partie où la seule personne avec qui
vous ne pouvez pas vous alliez ben oui
alors je sais pas j'ai peur de ne pas
vous avoir prix après grand chose mais
il fallait la faire le méchant jour
bioret amélioration
nourrit le populisme la querelle avec
les autres qui simplifie des sujets qui
sont extrêmement complexes bien raison
et bien non on ne participera pas de ses
vives de cette dérive la rive quelqu'un
que vous connaissez très bien qui est
dans le béarn qui s'appelle françois
bayrou
oui qu'est-ce qui va faire comme haut
commissaire au plan
sap a un petit côté suranné
c'est pas un peu enveloppé de naphtaline
tout ça oui enfin moi je trouve que l'on
découvre au fur et à mesure qu'on nous
avait parfois depuis des dizaines
d'années ce que moi j'ai vu la
disparition de tout le process la datar
le commissariat au plan et au fond nous
avait dit on nous invente francs
stratégie on nous invente un certain
nombre de structures nous ans ça va être
tellement mieux beaucoup plus moderne et
au fond n'avait pas inventé mieux à
l'époque alors ce n'est pas parce que
c'est un dispositif ancien que la
théorie de faisons table rase des
structures et d'aider des réflexions du
passé était à la mode qu'il faut pas se
poser la question d'avoir au travers
d'un commissariat au plan et françois
bayrou on sait très bien comme il a
toujours été sur des sujets assez
prospectifs le commissariat au plan il
est là pour regarder le monde et donc
essayé d'adapter mot quoi ne pas l'avoir
appelé le commissariat l'innovation
enfin vous êtes sur la terminologie mais
c'est pas mal de rappeler ce qui a été
le commissariat au plan le commissariat
au plan il a pu la porter la stratégie
industrielle il a porté la stratégie de
l'énergie qui à l'aide apportée la
stratégie lui reste deux minutes l
aménagement du territoire
je suis pas sûr que le commissariat au
plan doivent avoir honte pour ce qui
était de son passé de ce qu'ils avaient
fait il ya si on a envie d'avancer les
mêmes objectifs et je suis chaud à
l'oreille du président de la république
est ce que françois bayroux on peut
imaginer puisque c'est quand même une
élection qui pour lui est très
importante qui soit candidat à
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 ont
pas du tout que ce soit l'objectif qu'il
soit lé qui est le sien il chuchote
comme vous avez dit aurait dû présent
ils veulent la réussite du quinquennat
et donc ce n'est pas du tout le sujet
honnêtement oui pour parler souvent avec
lui ça n'est pas du tout son sujet son
sujet c'est de faire en sorte que nous
réussissions ce que nous essayons de
faire pour trois ans depuis trois ans et
dans les deux ans qui viennent et que
nous arrivions à retrouver aussi pour le
pays des perspectives un avenir est au
fond un peu d'optimisme
il faut qu'on arrive
c'est pas nous tous seuls on a besoin de
tout le monde pour le faire parce que je
pense que c'est une exigence qui n'est
pas une exigence personnelle davanture
individuel de président ça craint du
genou et je le dis vraiment pas ce que
je pense
nous voyons bien à quel point les
démocraties sont quand même chahuté
elle l'était avant le coc vide et
comment ils vont l'être après et comment
les mouvements populistes qui se
développe produisent quand même dans un
salon des talents
une dernière question 17 mois nous
séparent de l'élection présidentielle
grosso modo pour vous au gouvernement
vous avez un nom utile est ce que vous
pouvez me répondre franchement dix ans
et la vérité il n'y aura pas de réforme
des retraites ira pas dassieu de réforme
de l'assurance chômage
parce que vous n'aurez pas le temps de
la faire surtout dans le contexte de
crise sanitaire de l'enquêté j'ai
répondu tout à l'heure sur la question
des retraites en disant si nous n'avons
pas été un gouvernement
celui qui conduisait edouard philippe
comme celui que conduit jean castex nous
avons jamais éludé les questions et les
problèmes parce que ce que ce que les
gens ont fait comme griefs souvent aux
formations politiques ou responsables
publics c'est de passer leur temps à
dire qu'ils allaient réformer et pas
réformé nous nous avons réformé
est-ce qu'il ya besoin d'une réforme des
retraites la vérité c'est que oui bon
déjà de créer vous n'aurez pas le temps
non mais crée les conditions ça permet
d'avoir du temps si on est sur un débat
qui est plus cerné et qui a était bordée
avec un certain nombre d'organisations
syndicales représentants de salariés
patrons c'est plus facile que d'être
dans une confiture lité de même que
l'assurance chômage on a un sujet qui
est elle était dans un dans un schéma de
diminution du chômage vous voyez bien
que malheureusement le coc vide ne veut
pas sur cette pente et dont sa pause
hier plusieurs fois la tête au tchad qui
sera de combien la fin du quinquennat
d'après vous avec le avec les sanitaires
dépasser les 10%
je n'en sais rien en tout cas on fait
tout pour éviter et on est à l'oeuvre
pour essayer d'éviter on n'est pas là
pour être statisticiens et
prévisionnistes m'ont hélas pour agir
merci merci et à lundi prochain bien
évidemment bien sûr vous êtes chasseur
marché nous le confirme alors la chasse
à la glu a été interdite pour un an
pour vous est-ce qu'il faudrait
l'interdire totalement définitivement
royal fond et la forme
il me semble que bon c'est sûr des
chattes ce qu'on appelle des chasses
traditionnelles
vous aimez c'est le jeune homme de
chasse où je ne pratique pas la chasse à
la grand-font s'avancer pas de votre
région mais dans ma région je vais vous
aimez ça ce genre de chasse où je
comprends qu'elle puisse choquer encore
que personne ne connaisse bien ce qui se
passe il faut
je n'aime pas si c'est des oiseaux qui
se colle sur les branches que très
clairement il vient j'ai bien compris
quand j'explique comment on relâche
vivant pour ce qu'ils sont mon chat
sable et pour les autres qui servent
d'aplomb peu importe on va pas rentrer
dans le détail c'est ce qu'il faudrait
l'interdire des finales temps des
laissez moi finir parce que c'est plus
subtil que ça ce que je n'aime pas dans
cette affaire là c'est qu'on vienne
vilipendé montrer du doigt des gens qui
au fond exerce une tradition
multiséculaire c'est pas parce qu'elle
est multi séculaire que pour autant il
faut la maintenir
mais je pense que ça se fait ce qu'on
essaie de faire d'ailleurs au
gouvernement dans le dialogue et sans le
sentiment parfois qu'ont ces gens qui
sont dans une tradition je répète très
ancienne au fond qui vivait une
tradition sans avoir le sentiment de
commettre un crime d'accord d'accord
puisqu'il faudrait malgré des faits je
le dis en étant moi même chasseur mais
c'est passé si si si si ses lettres je
pense que le monde de la chasse il a
toutes les ressources en lui pour aussi
évolué pour aussi évolué sur des
pratiques qui sont moins compréhensible
la chasse à la glace mais mais ça doit
se faire dans une forme de respect de ce
que sont les bactéries sur un jeune
homme voilà il faut en parler il faut
faire tranquillement il faut le faire je
déteste le monde dans lequel on vit où
on procède par anathème et et noir ou
blanc annoncée des lois je sais des lois
qui autorisent ou qui interdit il
comprend qu'on puisse être passionné de
chasse à la glu je ne juge est pas l'eau
propre sur eux il faut qu'ils entendent
aussi qu'il ya des pratiques de chasse
qui tient mal comprise et sur lesquelles
il faut qu'on change rien eh bien vous
savez où il dort audition publique on
accueille deux parlementaires pour
débattre avec vous c'est ce qu'on va
faire maintenant
bonsoir sophie primas vous êtes
sénatrice et l'ère des yvelines
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques au sénat et bonsoir boris
vallot vous êtes démissionnaire des
landes et porte parole du parti
socialiste
sa fiche un peu voilà le temps que ça
s'affiche
c'est un petit peu bloqué ce sera mieux
la prochaine fois alors sophie primas
vous vous dites que il ya des choses à
revoir notamment sur ce que veut faire
le gouvernement sur certains
financements et vous brise vallot vous
voulez revenir aussi sur comment était
géré le corps est née des russes parce
qu'on appelait les premiers de cordée
c'est vous qui allez poser la première
question le sentiment que je crois on
peut tous partager c'est que cette crise
qui en révèle beaucoup d'autres qui lui
préexistaient au fond elle était un
ultimatum sociale et écologique et qu'
il nous a indiqué ce à quoi ce avec quoi
nous devions route c'est à dire un monde
invivable du fait des inégalités est
inhabitable
du fait du réchauffement climatique et
de ces deux points de vue là j'ai le
sentiment que dans la réponse qui est
apportée par le gouvernement
eh bien il ya un rendez vous manqué et
si je pose d'abord la question sociale
qui était imminente dans cette rentrée
avec beaucoup de souffrance des pertes
d'emplois des gens qui sont au chômage
ou ventes y être qu'ils sont encore
protégés pour un certain nombre d'entre
eux par le chômage partiel
j'ai le sentiment d'un rendez vous
manqué parce que dans ce plan de relance
il ya moins de 1% des crédits qui sont
consacrés qui sont destinés aux plus
précaires des françaises et des français
que la question de la justice est assez
absente de ce plan de relance la fois
dans le soutien à la demande qui est
parfaitement absent lors qu'il ya eu des
pertes très significatif de pouvoir
d'achat
songez que deux mois de confinement deux
mois de chômage partiel c'était 410
euros de perte de perte de revenus c'est
des étudiants qui sont en grande
précarité auxquels vous n'avez pas
proposer ou d'autres jeunes un revenu
qui leur permettrait d'être autonome ce
qu'il
ne pourront pas forcément être trouvé
donc voilà qu'avez vous fait pour
l'épauler premier de cordée pour les
caissières dont certains vous avez vu
chez chez auchan certaines vont être
probablement leur emploi vont être vont
être supprimés qu'avez vous fait pour
les éboueurs dans cette demeure que
justice l inversion des valeurs d
utilité sociale et nous qui se sont ré
les deux jours peut-être d'abord vous
dire que je partage je crois que
collectivement le coc vie doit nous
interroger sur un système
nous croyons tous pas forcément juste
d'ailleurs mais qui paraissait assez
immuable et une économie et un système
qui paraissait bien rodée mais au fond
ça doit nous interroger juste tout sur
la fragilité de nos systèmes économiques
et nous système géopolitique d'ailleurs
d'un point de vue global dont je partage
ce sentiment là dans la question vous
poser il ya me semble-t-il de questions
et comme vous le faites avec des mots
mesurés mais je vous connais j'essaie
d'y répondre
on peut pas dire que le gouvernement
français la politique française dans la
période de crise du coc vite dans
laquelle nous sommes encore été
complètement délier de la question
sociale
on a puissamment je crois que même vous
l'avez reconnu dans vos rangs on a
puissamment fait en sorte qu'on puisse
mettre en place un certain nombre d'
apporte d'amortisseur je pense au
dispositif de chômage perd cette
partielle qui ont évité ce qui s'est vu
dans beaucoup de pays d'europe et du
monde et je crois qu'on reconnaît à la
france d'avoir a mis en place du système
d'amortisseurs le plus puissant qui soit
par rapport à une crise qui pouvaient du
jour au lendemain le 17 mars ou le 17
avril met déjà en situation de chômage
c'est des milliards d'euros qui ont été
mis des dizaines de milliards d'euros
qui ont été mis pour immédiatement
éviter que des gens se trouvent en
situation de précarité
là on a besoin de préciser les choses
c'est dans le plan de relance le plan de
relance il est là pour faire en sorte
que l'économie reparte et que l'économie
reparte pas pour le plaisir du fait que
l'économie reparte parce que si
l'économie repart nous préserverons fois
et nous regretterons des emplois
là où je pense qu'il ya un sujet sur
lequel il faut qu'on ait une attention
particulière et vous verrez dans le
projet de loi de finances et le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale c'est ce qui était déjà au fond
dans la très grande précarité qu'il faut
accompagner
on a c'est peut-être insuffisant
je ne participe jamais de ceux qui
disent que ce que nous on est parfait et
ce qu'elle fait les autres avant était
imparfait mais je crois qu'on a fait des
choses en direction des étudiants on a
fait des choses en direction de l'aide
alimentaire
je pense que ça nécessite le plus d'être
évaluant continue parce qu apparaissent
des choses que nous n'avions pas vu le
jour
le grand rival au début et sur
lesquelles il faut juste positif on a on
a eu le sentiment d'une forme mais
rapidement cette inversion des priorités
et que la question de la précarité de la
justice était une question éminent
pardon de le dire mais l'insee en a
rendu les chiffres publics quelques
jours la pauvreté les inégalités ont
augmenté depuis le début du quinquennat
par les choix que vous avez fait des
choix fiscaux des choix sociaux sur les
1 pl on vous dira nous avions aimé
n'aurait pu imaginer que la crise crée
un électrochoc c'est vrai qu'il ya eu le
chômage partiel et c'est très bien vous
avez oublié tous ceux qui n'avaient pas
d'emploi comme vous continuez d'une
certaine manière de les ignorer ce que
disent les associations caritatives qui
sont très inquiètes de l'accroissement
de la pauvreté cela vous les avez oublié
parce que je crois qu'il n'est pas dans
vos dents vaut donc peut-être dans vos
logiciels que ceux qui n'ont pas
d'emploi et bien ont aussi besoin
rapidement marqué le réseau wallon
personne ne peut s'arroger quoi que ce
soit c'est dans notre logiciel aussi
s'occuper des plus précaires ça a été
fait peut-être qu'il faut faire plus
peut-être que le débat sarlat était
d'arriver finalement je crois que c'est
c'est jeu il faut faire plus vite mais
nous avons joué je me permets qui a fait
redémarrer les inégalités attendait et
la pauvreté sont allés qui le dit c'est
on laisse parc fénelon terminée il ya le
plus revaloriser un certain nombre de
minima sociaux ce qui n'avait pas été
fait dans le quinquennat précédent fiat
a fallu les inégalités la fête et qui à
ce que ces tribus alors qui a accru la
pauvreté ces messieurs vous ne me disiez
désagréable ce que vous les aironi
taille et que ça n'est pas parfait je
veux bien l'entendre je pense nous
faisons pas bien fort ce que vous êtes
encore le gouvernement de quel genre oui
enfin alors on a quand même mis en place
le système d'amortisseur social le plus
puissant du monde au travers va pas vous
mettre d'accord que ce soit quelque
façon porte at on ajouté
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît on
laisse maintenant sophie primas excepté
est insuffisant sophie primas vous
souhaitez poser une question vous sur la
méthode du gouvernement qui à vos yeux
pique de l'argent pour réinjecter dans
l'économie ça vous va pas très bien et
moi je voudrais pas être sur les grands
les grands schémas mais je voudrais
parler d'action logement accès au
logement c'est une organisation
paritaire qui pour nos téléspectateurs
gère ce qu'on appelait en 1953 le 1%
lieu un jour comme ça c'est l'un des
deux bras armé de l'état pour le
logement logements neufs le logement
social les opérations de rénovation
urbaine les opérations de coeur de ville
et donc le 9 septembre sans qu'il y ait
aucune négociation avec les syndicats
avec les organismes sociaux
eh bien on nous annonce une ponction
certaine au projet de loi de finances
d'un milliard d'action logement sans
négociation je me rappelle alors madame
wargon qui a été interrogé à la radio
offert une nouvelle mise logement faire
un procès en trésorerie en disant il ya
beaucoup de trésorerie et fait également
un procès en inefficacité je voudrais
une inefficacité d'action logement pour
aller plus vite pour construire
moi je voudrais simplement rappeler que
cette année on vient de prendre 500
millions d'euros avec ce jugement qu'on
a pris 300 2014 300 en 2015 que action
logement est engagé à hauteur de 1
milliard et demi dans les opérations de
revitalisation des coeurs de ville je
voudrais rappeler aussi que 7 milliards
d'économies ont été faits sur le
logement social par le gouvernement
quant à la gouvernance d'action
heureusement je voudrais de vous dire
que depuis 2018 la loi élan sur le
logement qui a été approuvée voté par le
parlement
il y avait des dispositions pour
améliorer la gouvernance et vous savez
puisqu'on à cette discussion assez
souvent ces dispositions ces décrets ne
sont jamais parus alors qu'allez vous
faire l'action logement c'est un des
bras armé du logement france c'est des
emplois c'est du logement pour les plus
précaires est ce que vous allez
sacrifier le court terme pour sacrifier
également le moyen terme les logements
dont parlait tout à l'heure au travers
des inégalités sociales la première
c'est celle du logement la présidente
jouets jeux c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet qui vous est cher et sur lequel
vous interrogez régulièrement le
gouvernement je commence par la fin sur
la question de la gouvernance où ma vie
interrogé sur wii c'est moi vous avez
interrogé interrogé par la voix d'une
question au gouvernement sur la question
de gouvernance c'est vrai que le décret
d'application a pris du retard et que la
ferme intention du gouvernement je crois
que ça avait été rappelée à l'époque par
julien de normandie et que c'est la
volonté de d'emmanuel wagon que de
sortir ce que sont les décrets
d'application effectivement la loi est
lent parce que j'entends tout à fait la
nécessité que action logement voit donc
dans quelques avril va être gouverné il
y avait un rapport qui devait être remis
il a été remis désormais on attendait ce
rapport est désormais
la loi sera plus clair sur les missions
d'action logement ces décrets mais
est-ce que moi le sentiment avec le coup
de poignard que vous donnez aujourd'hui
supplémentaires dans axa lentement c'est
de modifier complètement accents
jugement de ses parts et d'actions de
demain de détruire une vie à l'objet la
question financière
vous disiez à juste titre action
logement c'est le bras armé du
gouvernement
donc c'est quand même le bras armé du
gouvernement deuxième élément
je veux qu'il va pas se couper un bras
je voulais je fais pas c'est il est là
pour mettre en oeuvre une politique
gouvernementale est indécent que le
gouvernement regarde ce que fait action
logement et puisse aussi se poser la
question comment sont orientés les fonds
je fais pas de procès entend trésorerie
on a tous connu ça dans un certain
nombre d'organisations autant je
souviennent mais je parle sous votre
contrôle vraiment modestement je crois
qu'il ya dans l'action logements 8
milliards de trésorerie ont fait un
prélèvement d'un milliard le résultat
net de action logement en 2018 c'était
un milliard ou 1 milliard 2 bon il
semble que ça peut dans l'effort de
contribution qu'on peut faire les autres
ça ne déstabilise pas quand vous êtes
dans une structure qui peut avoir 8
milliards de trésorerie c'est sans doute
et c'est aussi le débat qu'on peut avoir
accès action logement que manifestement
un certain nombre de fonds qui ne sont
pas assez vite remobilisé mobilisés par
manque de lait versys ouifinance voyez
par manque d'âme ça ne date pas de vous
le reconnaîtrez on n'a pas cumulé 8
milliards de trésorerie depuis 2010 est
c'est vrai mais on n'a plus les
programmes de rénovation urbaine était
encore des données marsa sur les greens
était en retard depuis 2017 et avant
2017 va avoir 100 millions de mu
milliards de trésorerie prélèvement d'un
milliard je rappelle que d'ailleurs dans
le plan de relance sur un certain nombre
de dispositions qui seront faites pour
financer la rénovation énergétique y
compris dans les logements sociaux des
camps mais là on parle de logement
nettes de construction de chine s'est
toujours mis en retard vous vous
annoncer dans les plans de relance 5
semblait la clé sur le longue
semble-t-il
en tentant quand on regarde la situation
de la trésorerie me semble que la
question n'est pas l'argent d'action
logement la question c'est la
mobilisation d'action de logements pour
conquérir donc la gouvernance donc la
gouvernante les français on se rejoint
tout à fait mais sur le jugement ne va
pas être privé manifestement de moyens
parce que je pense que le problème cette
action logement plus déployer
complètement la politique
vous avez évoqué un mot qui s'appelle le
plan de relance ce monde en parle
évidemment c'est le gros morceau volume
et dit tout à l'heure du du budget qui
va être présentée 100 milliards bouhriz
à l'eau voulais en parler avec marc
fesneau de ce plan de relance la
question que je voudrais poser au
ministre c'est celle de savoir qui va
payer
ce plan de relance qui va payer la dette
publique pour partie vous avez déjà
répondu à cette question puisque pour ce
qui est de la lah parts sociales de la
dette qu vite vous l'avez transformer
transférés à la caisse d'amortissement
de la dette sociale vous avez donc
différer son remboursement et vous avez
augmenté les impôts de tous les français
non pas jusqu'en 2024 mais jusqu'en 2037
vous avez augmenté sur la période de
200% les impôts sociaux de les faire les
prélèvements sociaux de toutes les
françaises et tous les français sur des
impôts qui sont des impôts
proportionnels la crds ou la csg une
partie de la tva c'est à dire que vous
allez demander y compris à ceux que nous
avons applaudi à 20h de contribuer à
mêmes proportions que les plus riches
est la question que je voudrais poser
c'est pourquoi y at il une forme
d'obstination à exonérer ce qui pourrait
payer de l'effort légitime qu'on
pourrait demander comme les grandes
fortunes américaines l'ont fait après le
new deal comme les grandes fortunes
allemandes ont fait pour la
reconstruction ici on a le sentiment que
et bien c'est un tabou et que cette
question de la justice fiscale de
l'effort contributif que l'on pourrait
demander aux uns et aux autres il n'en
est jamais question à l'heure marc
fesneau
non monsieur valeo faut être précis et
vous l'êtes généralement s'agit pas
d'une augmentation d'impôts la crds
devait disparaître à terme de 2021
effectivement 2024 1024
on a décidé de maintenir la crds pas
seulement pour transférer une dette
c'est aussi pour pouvoir assurer une
première partie du financement de la
cinquième branche ce qu'il faut aussi
des financements
ce n'est pas une soyez précis au 6 mai
pour rembourser 136 milliards de dettes
que vous avez transférés à la cades s
décidant que tout le monde contribue ray
mais même manière non mais qui est pas
d'effort supplémentaire devant deux
lycées
c'est la logique c'est la logique du
financement eh bien eh bien eh bien elle
était pas été parfaitement 18 ha parce
qu'une dette qu'ovide aurait pu rester
une dette de l'état financé d'une autre
manière et notamment par la solidarité
certains d'entre eux le demande de à
leur marché on l'aura bien les etiassé
moi je suis je ne suis pas du tout gênée
avec l'idée que les plus fortunés payent
des impôts et nous sommes un pays où il
ya un impôt progressif ou les gens
payent des impôts vous nous ne cherchons
ticket qui étiez dégressif pourriez les
cendres il est supérieur on est le pays
du monde où les personnes qui sont les
plus riches payent le plus d'impôts faut
pas raconter de deux choses qui soient
des éléments faux et que les plus riches
contribuent beaucoup plus puissamment
que ceux qui ont moins de moyens j'ai
aucun problème là au bois tic avec ça
l'impôt sur le revenu est dégressif pour
les sentiers sont ils les plus les plus
élevés le à l'ex patron sans dépasser le
patron de 262 grandes entreprises il ya
une 300 fois ce que gagne une question
de sujet c'est la question des facultés
contributives qui peuvent payer sa dette
là vous voulez bien on vient régler le
libre et puisque il vient par contre 6
anticipé si vous ne faites pas ce
monsieur veut abri des regards de
reprise alors révélé marc fesneau sur le
rétablir une justice à payer l'impôt
monsieur monsieur val aux caissières
mais les messieurs va ouvrir ce sont les
mois les cdc budgétaire c'est jacqueline
des siècles s'est payé au smic est pas
là pour vous pose je vous pose la
question à 50% pas les appelle pas été
verni par les violences et vous parlez
de la part sur l'a16 s'il vous plaît
sont plus là stressant de leurs revenus
oui mais le dlc répond par deux titres
ça ne dit pas que e on ne met pas la
crds qu'une sur vannes oc on essayait de
faire à savoir les débats caricaturaux
ce n'est pas qu'ils aient un caractère
sûr je bossais pour des toujours plus
tôt me contre en 2010 est en 2020 quand
on est dans l'opposition de venir donner
des leçons quand en 2000
2012 de la vie rien et bien françois
hollande l'avait rétabli l'impôt sur la
fortune
vous devriez assez l'impôt sur la
rétabli il avait rétabli la parité entre
la fiscalité du capital et du travail
vous n'avez eu de cesse que en rien de
mal et marc fesneau amour général
anglais parfait nous nous sommes
monsieur valls répondent comme le seul
gouvernement qui a décidé alors ça
suffit
venez vous avez passé dans l'inventaire
national oui les secourir et s'il vous
plaît pour but que s'il vous plaît en
france moi j'avais se laisser finir par
feydeau et puis après sophie d'accueil
fini à temps qu'au lit d'enfant tour
on pourrait me laisse convaincre mais au
moins on pourrait écouter ça serait
super vraiment je vous assure c'est
vraiment essayer tous sympas donc nous
sommes le seul gouvernement qui a décidé
sur la question de la fiscalité locale
de supprimer la taxe d'habitation ça a
nourri des débats d'ailleurs parfois
difficiles avec le sénat s'était pas une
mesure de justice sociale s'était pas
une baisse d'impôts pour les plus
modestes
non non il me suis endetté ci ne payez
pas non mais vous voyez là mais ce n'est
pas vrai et les 20% et les 20% de
français kiki qui tente encore
assujettis à la taxe d'habitation pour
lequel on est dit et je crois que c'est
43% riri de cette suppression de la taxe
d'habitation est que vous pensez qu'ils
ont besoin qui pourrait pas contribuer à
la solidarité de relatives bonnes
questions d une réponse attendait la
réponse monsieur vélo vous savez très
bien que ce n'était pas le dispositif
est la volonté du gouvernement
simplement le conseil constitutionnel et
face à l'égout l'obligation d'égalité
devant l'impôt a décidé qu'il fallait
supprimer pour tout le monde donc ce
n'est pas une vérité du gouvernement
nous étions bien sûr les vins pas lors
des 20 derniers pourcents qu'il avait
continué la toujours pas si on rejoue
augmenté d'une autre manière alors vous
boris vannes où il parlait du
financement du plan de relance sophie
primas vous vous êtes allé voir dans le
temps de relancer vous dites mais du
côté des énergies renouvelables quelque
chose qui va pas il le compte n'y est
pas en fait ce qu'on ne comprend pas
bien monsieur le ministre en fait
l'articulet ce serment est la cohérence
entre à la fois la loi énergie climat
sur lequel on a quelques souvenirs
communs notamment d'agenda allumant la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
les annonces qui sont faites dans le
plan de relance et puis la réalité des
actes qui sont pris aujourd'hui je vous
prendre quelques exemples
en juin le sénat a voté une douzaine de
mesures pour la relance verte qui ont
été refusées par le gouvernement et donc
par l'assemblée nationale et qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans le plan de
relance pourquoi on
du 6 mois pourquoi monsieur le ministre
on a perdu ses six mois je prends un
deuxième exemple l'hydrogène aujourd'hui
c'est une très bonne chose vous annoncer
un plan de déploiement sur l'hydrogène
verts en particulier avec 2 milliards
mais dans le plan de déploiement qui a
été annoncé en 2018 on avait fléché vous
aviez fléché 100 millions d'euros qui
n'ont jamais été atteints
comment on va dans les actes passés de
l'annonce aa la réalité et puis je finis
par une 3e troisième acte qui me tient
beaucoup à coeur en ce moment puisque
c'est demain matin que ça se passe
demain matin décret va passer qui va
annoncer une une diff une part dans une
une réalisation modifications pardon des
tarifs de rachat du méthane vert voilà
qui revient sur des actes d' engagements
qui ont été pris auprès de gens qui ont
investi dans les méthaniseurs dans les
mêmes méthaniseur et en particulier les
agriculteurs et qui va venir
déséquilibré cette filière mais tu n y
l'heure où est la cohérence
où est le chemin là vous avez deux
minutes pour répondre à tous aïe aïe aïe
aïe comme deux éléments qui paraissent
intéressants vous dit à juste titre
parfois que vous portez des mesures et
qu'on retrouve après au fond c'est une
question de temporalité peut-être de
dialogue entre le sénat où l'assemblée
nationale et le gouvernement
je veux bien en prendre acte mais au
fond vous dites que ça de ce point de
vue là si je comprends bien ce que vous
dites je peux pas trahir votre propos
c'est plutôt d'accord avec la mesure sur
la question sur la question de la
méthanisation et du décret je vais pas
les éléments du débat d'où ils sont
composés là vous me posez c'est de la
technique mais la question c'est la
colère ailleurs vous disiez se moque de
ce qu'on a besoin mais c'est une
exigence qu'on doit tous porter c'est
vrai qu'on porte parfois des messages et
des objectifs et après on a des
difficultés à mettre en oeuvre et à
trouver les moyens et tout l'enjeu c'est
à coup sûr là dessus je voulais rebondir
et l'exigence que vous pouvez porter
vous comme parlementaire et c'est bien
légitime c'est de faire en sorte que les
moyens qui sont mis à disposition ils
soient réellement mise en oeuvre est
réellement messaoudi putsch ribas est
pas le cas et s'il n'y a pas de
cohérence est vous dira non
intéressez-vous à ce décret parce que
c'est demain matin qu'il ait signé les
jeunes gens tout ce que dit sophie
vraiment dix ans on avait mis 100
millions sur l'hydrogène on n'a pas
avancé vous allez mettre deux milliards
comment vous pourriez dépensé deux
milliards alors que vous n'avez pas
dépenser 100 millions et ça c'est une
exigence est le premier ministre a
rappelé et rappellent en permanence aux
ministres charge aussi aux
parlementaires d'être les aiguillons je
pense que c'est utile qu'il le soit pour
dire ça n'avance pas les dossiers
n'avancent pas ya trop de procédure et
ça complique les choses
entendu ce fip rien boris va nous faire
avancer le gouvernement à merci en tout
cas d'être venu faire avancer qu'il a ce
soir sur le plateau de d'auditions
publiques c'était avec des questions
vraiment préparé et ça donne vous avez
je laisse puisque évidemment on se
contente pas de mettre en désaccord en
fait des propositions elles sont
rarement entendu par l'exécutif mais
enfin ça bon je me fais plaisir quand
même offrir blinis voyons on va garder
nos construit sur terre mais promis on
lui pour lui donne si oui voilà oui
j'aurais pas contaminés merci merci
merci le rima merci à vous on va faire
un détour maintenant par le figaro live
où nous attend vincent roux façon vous
êtes avec nous soit bonsoir bonsoir ravi
de vous retrouver marino alors sur le
figaro live vous suivez ce que disent
les lecteurs les téléspectateurs les
internautes sur l'actualité alors quoi
ce soir alors bien sûr ce qui est très
commentée ce sont les dernières
décisions qui ont été annoncées autour
du cornât virus c'est contre la
propagation du coronavirus on débat
beaucoup sur l'interdiction ou non
d'interdire les rassemblements familiaux
ça ça d'à côté les certains internautes
sont favorables d'autres sont indignés
par le fait qu'on s'en prenne aux
familles mais c'est notamment les
décisions qui sont prises en région à
marseille
et avant ça à bordeaux jérôme nous dit
par exemple la surenchère a commencé
qu'elle est ce blizzard pays est réputé
jacobins qui soudain délègue la décision
au préfet l'état donne l'impression
d'une ivresse étrangers demandent au
préfet date n'est un rôle qui ne lui
sied plus alors j'ai bien compris marc
fesneau que vous vous avez horreur de
faire des généralités mais est ce que
vous avez à répondre à cet internaute
qui justement s'indigne de voir comme
beaucoup d'autres internautes des
finalement des décisions assez bien
outre à victoire marc fesneau
je compte cinq alors il peut y avoir
parfois des décisions contradictoires
mais je pense que la situation d'un
territoire est différente de la
situation d'un autre territoire et qu'il
faut
il faut accepter que la situation ici de
marseille la de guéret ne soient pas les
mêmes et parfois on a le sentiment dans
la première phase du coc vide
en tout cas les citoyens français ont le
sentiment que tout le monde était en
confirmant généralisée quand la tension
sanitaire n'était pas la même d'un
territoire à l'autre il faut accepter
quand même que dans notre état quand
bien même ils soient jacobins où on
laisse quand même une marge
d'appréciation pas seulement aux préfets
votre interlocuteur ou votre auditeurs
disait le préfet non le préfet les
collectivités locales et j'entendais
l'esprit de responsabilité des
responsables de ces collectivités qui
disait il ya un certain nombre de choses
qu'on ne peut pas faire dans notre
territoire ce qu'on met en danger la
situation la situation sanitaire voilà
donc la réponse merci vincent et merci
aussi à vous marchez no mercy avoir
participé à auditions publiques ce
premier numéro de la saison voilà
deuxième saison que j'ai l'honneur de
présenter c'est toujours un plaisir
audition publique revient lundi en
direct à 19h30 évidemment bonne soirée
[Musique]